Ich wünsche mir nichts sehnlicher
als eine Beziehung.
Dating während Corona
ist kompliziert.
Neue Menschen kennenlernen?
Fast unmöglich.
Sie lieben sich.
Diese Schweine haben das
bessere Sexleben als ich momentan.
Ah ja, im Bett, mit Hundeblick.
Nein! Lame.
Lame.
Viele von uns sitzen
seit Jahresbeginn zu Hause rum.
Keine Hobbys, keine Partys, kein Sex.
Dating-Apps wie Tinder und Grindr
sind jetzt für viele Singles
die einzige Möglichkeit,
jemanden kennenzulernen.
Er möchte genaue Grössenangaben zu
meinem besten Stück. So läuft das.
Ist das normal?
- Auf Grindr ist das total normal.
"It's a match."
Dann gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten:
Entweder trifft man sich draussen
mit Abstand oder direkt zu Hause.
Auf Distanz oder sehr nahe.
Es ist so anstrengend.
Ich will herausfinden,
was diese Pandemie mit Singles macht.
Ich selber date nicht.
Ich bin in einer Beziehung.
Aber meine Mitbewohnerin Isabelle
ist Single.
Sie hat es aktuell aufgegeben, jeman-
den über Dating-Apps kennenzulernen.
Sie hat Tinder gelöscht -
zu kompliziert.
Ich weiss aber, dass sie es
ab und zu trotzdem nutzt,
besonders,
wenn sie im Shutdown einsam wird.
Why not try?
Irgendwie trotzdem - keine Ahnung -
daten, schreiben, kennenlernen.
Was fehlt ...
... ist schon menschliche Nähe.
Klar, einerseits körperlich,
aber andererseits auch emotional.
Meinst du,
das fehlt jetzt wegen Corona?
Ja.
Sobald die Zahlen stiegen,
beschränkte ich mich
auf den engsten Freundeskreis.
So lernst du
keine neuen Leute mehr kennen.
Im Januar habe ich ausser euch und
meiner Familie niemanden gesehen.
Das ist für mich ganz klar zu wenig.
Tinder?
Bist du bereit?
- Mh, ja.
Also, was mich interessiert:
Wein, Comedy, Netflix.
Ja, Politik.
Nein, nein, Wandern auf keinen Fall.
Mutig.
- Mit dem "God is bread" im Bild.
Ich sage, das ist dein lucky shot.
Gut. Ich hoffe,
ich habe nichts zwischen den Zähnen.
Dein Umgang mit Tinder
ist bereits ziemlich leger.
Ja, ja,
man hat sich halt daran gewöhnt.
Gut, da sind wir.
Cute.
Was sind deine Kriterien?
- Weiss nicht.
Das ist ein schlechtes Bild.
Das oben ohne.
Der meint, er sei ein Engel.
Und so LinkedIn-Bilder?
Einfach nein.
Irgendwann
musst du Regeln aufstellen.
Denn man hat viel zu viele Matches
und Leute, die schreiben.
Als Frau musst du Regeln aufstellen.
Oder willst du jeden liken?
Oh, der hat schöne Haare.
Das Ding ist wirklich ...
- "It's a match."
Das ging megaschnell.
Schau mal, wenn ich
ihm jetzt schreibe - "hey" -,
schreibt er sicher nicht zurück.
Und dann ...
Ah ja, im Bett, mit Hundeblick.
Nein! Lame, lame, lame.
O Gott, was ist das? Nein.
Ich bin voll schlimm.
Richtig gemein.
Du bist sehr oberflächlich, oder?
Ja, dafür ist diese App gemacht.
Macht das nichts mit dir,
wenn du dir vorstellst,
dass dich umgekehrt auch jemand
innert 0,2 Sek. abstempelt?
Deshalb ... war ich
länger nicht mehr auf Tinder.
Es ist nicht sehr geil, wie ein
Stück Fleisch behandelt zu werden.
Mein Bedürfnis ist,
als Mensch wahrgenommen zu werden.
Als ebenbürtig,
als gleichberechtigt.
Als ... auch liebenswert.
Das gibt mir Tinder nicht.
Das gibt mir
vielleicht ein erstes Treffen.
Das ist momentan halt schwierig.
Das machst du nicht.
Das findet momentan
in meinem Leben nicht statt.
Nina hat gerade richtig viel
mit Online-Dating zu tun.
Sie meldete sich
auf Instagram bei mir,
als ich Leute für diesen Film suchte.
Sie wohnt alleine, arbeitet
wegen Corona viel von zu Hause aus.
Ihre Dates finden manchmal
auch in ihrer Wohnung statt.
Wie waren deine Dates diese Woche?
Ja ... Es geht so.
- Oje.
Ich habe entschieden,
eine Pause zu machen.
Es ist so anstrengend.
Am Sonntag hatten wir
einen wirklich schönen Abend
und verstanden uns gut.
Aber beim Verabschieden ...
Ich weiss nicht, ob er mich küssen
oder auf die Wange küssen wollte.
Schräg.
Während COVID darf man nichts,
ausser sich zu Hause treffen.
Du überspringst einen Schritt.
Sonst gehst du was trinken
und dann entweder:
"Ich gehe alleine nach Hause",
oder: "Du kommst mit."
Jetzt triffst du dich
schon zu Hause.
Viele Männer scheinen es nicht
richtig einschätzen zu können,
wenn man sich
in einem intimen Rahmen kennenlernt.
Mhm.
Kollege, wir sind
in einer verdammten Pandemie,
verpiss dich mit deinem Mund.
Das muss man zuerst besprechen.
Oder wenn
einer kommen und sagen würde:
"Bill Gates ist an allem schuld",
möchte ich den nicht daten.
Es gibt Aspekte, wo man evtl.
nicht auf einer Wellenlänge ist.
Ich dir auch, danke.
- Wir hören uns. Bis dann.
Mein Eindruck vom Dating
während Corona:
Es ist schwierig, mit dem Verhältnis
von Nähe und Distanz klarzukommen.
Nina hat mich
zu sich nach Hause eingeladen.
Sie will mir mehr
zu ihrem Dating-Leben erzählen.
Zuerst treffe ich aber Lou.
Auch er hat Trouble beim Dating.
Er ist seit 14 Jahren Single.
Seit der Corona-Pandemie
sehnt er sich immer mehr nach einer
Beziehung und nach Zweisamkeit.
Ich finde das sehr verständlich,
ehrlich gesagt.
Im vergangenen Herbst
lernte er einen Mann kennen,
sie schrieben einander viel
und nutzten FaceTime.
Wegen der Pandemie
sahen sie einander aber nie in echt.
Lou erzählte mir,
dass er ein bisschen verknallt ist.
Aber momentan
läuft es leider nicht so toll.
Hallo, freut mich.
Es ist sehr schwierig.
Seit gefühlten zwei Wochen ...
... eher Funkstille.
Nur noch sporadisch Kontakt.
Ich habe versucht ...
Ich bin relativ leger.
Man hätte sich ja auf
einen Spaziergang treffen können,
mit den social distancing rules,
und sich so kennenlernen.
Aber das klappte nicht.
Ich bekam nur noch sporadisch
einen Gruss.
Normalerweise gab es
ein Morgen-Selfie im Bad
mit einer zertrümmerten Fresse.
Oder wie man sich
halt sonst authentisch zeigt.
Das war der Alltag.
Wir haben
nicht alles schöngeredet,
sondern wir haben versucht,
real life digital mitzugeben.
Das ist irgendwie
seit zwei Wochen sehr schwierig.
Ich merke:
Du bist ein bisschen traurig.
Ja.
Ich habe auch etwas aufgebaut.
Zusammengefasst, im Moment ...
Dadurch, dass ich
mich etwas contactless fühle,
habe ich etwas aufgebaut.
Heute schaue ich es nicht direkt als
Fehler an, aber als waste of time.
Ich hätte mich ja stattdessen um
einen anderen Bären bemühen können.
Ich weiss, ziemlich zickig.
Du weisst es noch nicht.
Es gab noch kein klärendes Gespräch.
Das klärende Gespäch zu dem,
was mein Bauchgefühl sagt,
nämlich dass es einen Nebenbuhler
gibt, hatten wir noch nicht.
"Hoi, mein Lieber,
ich hoffe, es geht dir gut."
"Hattest du
einen schönen Tag im Schnee?"
"Wie sieht es aus mit dem Call?"
Krass, welche Beziehung
Lou zu einem Mann aufgebaut hat,
den er noch nie gesehen hat.
Er scheint sich sehr stark
Nähe zu wünschen.
Nina erzählte mir vor einigen Tagen
etwas ganz anderes:
Ihr kommen die Typen
zu schnell zu nahe.
Darüber will ich mit ihr reden.
Dann dort rüber. Warten wir,
bis wir von der Strasse weg sind.
Den einen habe ich
über Tinder kennengelernt.
Wir telefonierten ein paarmal,
lernten uns besser kennen.
Danach wollten wir uns
auf einen Spaziergang treffen.
Es stürmte aber so sehr, dass
ich sagte: "Easy, komm zu mir."
Man merkte, es war eine komische ...
Es war einfach anders,
viel weniger ungezwungen.
Er sagte, er habe sich schon lange
mit niemandem mehr getroffen,
ausser mit dem engsten Umfeld.
Da fängt's schon an.
Man befindet sich
in der Privatsphäre,
gleichzeitig
kennt man einander noch nicht.
Er kam mir am Anfang ziemlich nahe.
Irgendwann
setzte ich mich woanders hin.
War es dir unangenehm?
Er war 15 Min. bei mir
und setzte sich so nahe zu mir.
Es ist ziemlich strange, wenn du
innerhalb von 15 Min. glaubst,
du müsstest
dich so nahe zu einer Frau setzen,
unabhängig von einer Pandemie.
Ich kenne keine Frau,
die das total geil findet.
Schau, das ist mein Lieblingsplatz.
Das ist ein kleiner Bauernhof.
Ah, schau!
Sie lieben sich.
Diese Schweine haben das
bessere Sexleben als ich momentan.
Der andere, den ich traf,
kam mir am Schluss auch zu nahe.
Er sah das aber nicht wirklich ein.
Er fand, er sei anderen,
die er weniger faszinierend finde,
näher gekommen.
Ich finde halt ...
- Doofer Spruch.
Ich will seine Meinung dazu
gar nicht hören,
er hat das einfach zu akzeptieren.
Sonst kann er mich am A... Ja.
Deshalb habe ich momentan ...
keinen Bock.
Aber ich weiss nicht recht,
wie ich es ihnen sagen soll.
Deshalb legen wir nachher Karten.
Du legst Karten, um herauszufinden:
Wie sage ich diesen Männern,
dass ich keinen Bock auf sie habe?
Spezifische Antworten
geben die Karten nicht.
Ich merke: Nina hat gerade etwas
die Nase voll von Boys und Tinder.
Verständlich, sage ich da nur.
Das ist Till. Er hat heute
seit Langem mal wieder ein Date.
Er lernte sie auf
einer Dating-App kennen. Wo sonst?
Ich darf leider nicht mit zum Date,
aber vorher einige Fragen stellen.
Wie lange hattest du kein Date mehr?
Grössenordnung?
Ca. vier Monate.
Ich hatte ...
... im Sommer und Herbst
einige Treffen
auf einen Kaffee
und einen Spaziergang.
Über die Festtage
legte ich eine Pause ein.
Ich merkte selber, dass ich
sehr oft auf Tinder und Bumble war
und dann wieder weg.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass ich
sehr oft an dieser App hing.
Das gefiel mir nicht.
Deshalb fand ich eine Pause gut.
Jetzt wollte ich dem
noch eine Chance geben -
oder bin ihm wieder verfallen,
weiss nicht.
Allgemein?
Ist das ein Abenteuer für dich?
Ja, gerade in dieser Zeit,
in der ich meine sozialen Kontakte
heruntergefahren habe,
ist es ein Tapetenwechsel.
Es ist ...
ausserhalb der Komfortzone.
Ich lerne einen neuen Menschen
kennen, das ist ein erster Schritt.
Es ist aufregend,
Adrenalin wird ausgeschüttet.
Uh, the rush.
Ich werde selber nervös.
Immerhin macht das schöne Wetter
Dating wieder etwas einfacher.
Spaziergang, statt direkt
zu jemandem nach Hause zu müssen.
Irgendwie beruhigend.
Zurück bei Lou.
Er versucht,
seinen Schwarm zu erreichen,
er will ihn zur Rede stellen.
Nein, er hat
noch immer nicht geschrieben.
Aber Lou hat einen Back-up-Plan.
Seit zwei Wochen ist er
wieder aktiv auf Dating-Apps.
Du sprachst vorher von Grindr.
Da schreibt jemand auf Grindr.
Zeig mal, was auf Grindr geht.
Ja, feel free.
"Ein Bild gesendet".
Ich öffne es nicht.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es
direkt eindeutige Bilder sind.
Aber es vibriert gerade.
Du fragtest, ich ging online
und schon ratterte es.
Das ist ja schon cool.
Du gehst online
und der eine oder andere
zeigt schon Interesse,
schickt dir irgendwelche Taps.
Das gibt Bestätigung.
Aber damit allein
ist es nicht getan.
Da müsste etwas kommen, ob es
die schnelle Nummer ist oder nicht.
Hier ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Du musst es aber wohl verstecken.
Er schrieb am 14. September -
interessierte mich nicht.
Heute schreibt er wieder.
Er will schon Grössenangaben zu
meinem besten Stück. So läuft das.
Ist das normal?
Auf Grindr ist das sehr normal, ja.
Hast du das Gefühl, die Typen dort
sind anders seit Corona?
Schwierig.
Ich bin seit zwei Wochen
wieder dabei.
Es ist relativ simpel,
aber manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
es gehe nur um
die schnelle Wichsvorlagennummer.
Statt dass man einen Porno schaut,
schickt man sich dick pics.
Nicht mal Sex im echten Leben.
Nein, wirklich nicht.
Ich glaube,
es hat sich auch hier verändert.
Die schnellen Hook-ups
finden jetzt ... nicht statt.
Ich wünsche mir nichts sehnlicher
als eine Beziehung.
Einfach mal einen, der ...
Es geht nicht nur um den Sex,
sondern ums gemeinsame Frühstück,
auf dem Sofa einen Film schauen,
Spiele machen, Spaziergang.
Sport ist Mord für mich, aber
sogar das würde ich in Kauf nehmen.
Ich würde sogar wandern gehen,
wenn er das möchte.
Ich bin nicht ein Mensch, der
alleine in dieser Wohnung sein kann.
War ich schon vorher nicht,
jetzt noch sehr viel weniger.
14 Jahre Single hin oder her, mit
dem Image der Dragqueen as well,
aber es wäre langsam an der Zeit,
dass mal einer bleiben würde.
Wenn du das nach 14 Jahren -
und gerade mit dieser Pandemie -
nicht hast,
suchst du den Fehler bei dir.
Dabei musst du realisieren:
Du bist gut so, wie du bist.
Das musste ich erst lernen.
Combox.
Na?
- Hallo.
Wie war's?
- Gut.
Es war angenehm.
Wir sprachen viel übers Studium
und über Sport.
Aber ... Es war sehr angenehm, ja.
Was habt ihr gemacht?
Wir spazierten
bis zur ... Chinawiese
und setzten uns dort.
Schön mit dem Zürichsee
und dem Bergpanorama.
Dann spazierten wir wieder zurück.
Die Frage aller Fragen: Kannst du
dir vorstellen, sie wiederzusehen?
Ich glaube schon.
Ich lasse es noch etwas sacken,
aber ich kann es mir gut vorstellen.
Die Frage ist,
ob es ihr gleich geht.
Das ist immer schwierig
herauszufühlen.
Aber, ja ...
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, mich
in den nächsten Tagen zu melden.
Befolgst du die Drei-Tage-Regel?
Nein, ich denke nicht.
Wenn es stimmt, dann melde ich mich.
Vielleicht meldet auch sie sich.
Wer weiss?
Fast ein Happy End bei Till.
Er scheint zu wissen,
was er will.
Bei Nina ist es komplizierter.
Sie wendet sich bei Gefühlschaos
gerne mal an die Karten.
Manchmal ist man unsicher,
ob man sich auf seine Gefühle
und Entscheidungen verlassen kann.
Manchmal ist man unsicher
und froh, etwas zu haben.
Ob das nun ein Freund ist,
der etwas bestätigt,
oder ein Zeichen.
Einige Menschen
bitten um ein Zeichen.
Ich benutze diese Intuitionskarten.
Wofür brauchst du sie heute?
- Ich schaue ...
Mir schreiben zwei Männer.
Ich weiss nicht wirklich,
wie ich damit umgehen soll.
Eigentlich habe ich kein Interesse.
Aber ich weiss nicht recht,
was ich tun soll.
Wenn ich über die Karten fahre,
fühle ich mich
von einer bestimmten angezogen.
Wenn ich sie berühre
und ein Kribbeln spüre,
weiss ich: Das ist die richtige.
Dann drehe ich sie um.
Dann ziehe ich
die Vergangenheitskarte.
Du musst sie jeweils
selber interpretieren.
Es passt relativ gut.
Diese interpretiere ich so: Mach dir
keine Gedanken über diese Typen
oder darüber,
wie du das lösen kannst,
sondern geniess deinen Tag.
Und die?
Die ist ziemlich selbsterklärend.
Was ist das? Regelmässig meditieren.
Ich interpretiere es so:
Sorge weiterhin dafür, dass du eine
gewisse Ruhe und innere Mitte hast.
Alles entspannt nehmen
und schauen, wie es läuft.
So würde ich diese Karte
interpretieren.
Nicht? Oh, jetzt aber.
Die helfen dir auch, oder?
- Auf jeden Fall.
Schau, wie süss die sind.
Bleibst du noch eine Weile
Tinder-abstinent?
Hm, ja ...
Momentan habe ich keine Lust,
wieder anzufangen, sagen wir's so.
Aber ich kann es
nicht abschliessend beantworten.
Aber momentan ... überlege ich eher,
wie ich die loswerde,
die ich an der Backe habe,
als dass ich noch mehr möchte.
Meine Mitbewohnerin
hat sich nach wenigen Stunden
wieder von Tinder verabschiedet.
Sie gibt die Hoffnung auf,
jemanden kennenzulernen,
und hat keinen Bock mehr
auf das oberflächliche Hin und Her.
Genau das merke ich.
Und das ist mir sehr wichtig:
dass ein Mann auf das eingeht,
was ich sage.
Dann fühle ich mich ernst genommen.
Es ist ja fast bewundernswert,
wenn man jedes Gespräch
in die Richtung von Sex drehen kann.
Ja, eh, Sex ist geil und alles.
Aber ... es ist nicht alles.
Und für ...
Für eine Partnerschaft,
egal in welcher Form,
wünsche ich mir, ernst genommen
zu werden. Easy as that.
Oder auch nicht.
Als ich schon fast fertig bin
mit dieser Reportage,
meldet sich Lou erneut -
er will mir etwas erzählen.
Wie geht's?
- Gut. Wochenende.
Ich glaube, meine zickige Art
vor einigen Wochen war begründet,
aber vielleicht
einen touch too much.
Also, los, erzähl von deinem Date.
Wie war es?
Die erste Begegnung
fand an der Haustür statt.
Er kam direkt zu mir nach Hause.
Ich fuhr
mit meinen besten Kochkünsten auf
und es war ein super ...
... cozy Abend.
Die Erwartungen wurden erfüllt.
Inwiefern?
Menschlich.
Das mal live kennenlernen zu dürfen.
Das war ...
War er so, wie du
ihn dir vorgestellt hattest?
Fast noch besser. Ja.
Er ist wirklich ein Bär.
Wir gönnten uns ein Glas Champagner.
Wir führten ...
sehr tiefgründige Gespräche,
die unabhängig von ...
Man muss sich mal kennenlernen,
live.
Dann stellt man Fragen.
Ja, es gab einen Kuss
und Kuscheln auf dem Sofa.
Es gab einen Kuss?
- Ja.
Wir haben rumgemacht,
auf gut Deutsch.
War es schön für dich?
Ja. V.a., weil ich schon lange
nicht mehr geknutscht habe.
Ich war ziemlich müde,
da ich gearbeitet hatte.
Anscheinend schnarchte ich laut
an seiner Seite.
Es störte ihn nicht.
Ein gutes Zeichen.
Ich fand auch ...
Neben einem Mann,
in meinem Territorium ...
Wenn ich mich so fallen lassen kann,
dass ich neben jemandem einschlafen
kann - nicht aus Langeweile -,
ist das für mich eine Bestätigung,
dass da ...
der Richtige an meiner Seite ist.